hello and welcome to this video playing
nods yeah and this is an opening request
I got an opening request by former
student of mine one of my first ever
online chess students he requested me to
play a three against the Sicilian this
is not really what I believe is great
but I'm going to try maybe I can
actually get to my my system where this
one c4 with the temple up that's
actually funny maybe I can get that in
question is if that tempo is actually
useful I mean it's a playable position
nothing terribly great but definitely
something you can play Bishop 2 a2 must
always do this retreat to step out of
possible Tempe
oh that's uncommon
[Music]
to copy 5 here and then play for the
square one
there are other ideas just f4f was kind
of a double-edged decision in a way it
looks right yeah because the bishop
points towards f7 and therefore I get
there they are looking to play in a way
but on the other hand I might activate
this Bishop a piece that he just has
made pretty bad with you 5 I mean he has
this ball Vinick pawns formation with c5
e5 but the knight on f6 is not ideally
placed and I have a pretty good setup
against it because I have so many some
sort of control over d5 so I'm curious
what he's doing now this one yeah here I
mean okay I'll move first thing later Oh
interesting
Bishop to b6 oh I can't take Y F F 5 is
a move I think I'm just going to take
and go for more yeah maybe more natural
continuation just takes it
I don't know yeah let's go Knight takes
Queen to e7 me black is okay yeah I
guess it's nothing I don't have anything
special d5 is not playable fortunately
so gotcha
double on the F ow
yeah this is doing alright it's doing
all right I think I wonder if I should
play Knight to d1 + c3 if that is an
idea can I not just take on g6 okay
yeah I'm on the woodpecker method doing
tactics every day which doesn't video
didn't help last game that's anyway
what kind of sound is that it's really
we did yeah I mean it is not just a pawn
I'm just just killing him I think on the
King Bishop h6 is coming it should be
pretty much over Queen g5 next step but
if you move the bishop somewhere
I have Queen g5 oh I didn't see that
move
okay it's still winning but I didn't see
it how do we win here actually what is
the best way to do it
Bishop g7 rook g7 Bishop g7 Queen takes
pawn takes a5 what is best I can also
take d7 here's that intermediate check
okay I'm not certain what's best when
this is looking quite quite convincing I
think Queen takes Bishop h6 should do
the trick keeping the bishop and there
is no way to escape the caption
so what to do there's an immediate way
to win look at five or something maybe
not yet but I can just play with the
extra piece yeah he was perfectly fine
until he blundered into 90s g6 yeah that
a3 is not great yeah but it was a
request so I played it and one idea of
this move it seems to be instead often
it moves like this yeah you can go
before for a for a gambit I really have
my doubts about all this but it's it's
it's it has been tried it seems
something something like that is
supposed to be the idea and maybe I'm in
a blitz game that could be enough
something like that
yeah g6 now after after before Bishop g7
I have to play this one which looks odd
at best so I rather develop a piece in
this with g6
it is not super easy for him to play
this kind of thing here because of the
laughs the dark squares not a big deal
but yeah I mean this is probably about
equal
I think blankets close to quality with
them with colors reversed and the tempo
helps if I Fitz not believe that I feel
is so natural here because of that d5
square that looks weakened I mean it
cannot be like super terrible but it's
not something that what would cross my
mind a form that is possible Bishop
Bishop g5 is a very clinical way to
treat this simply let's say here and you
you take and then you say okay am I've
got three pieces
to control with d5 you only have to to
compete for the square still it's not
clear that this is something great I
mean c3 King age 7 and black is f5 and I
don't know if that is really something
the engine points out the f4 in this
position which is interesting maybe this
is the only way to justify the solar
idea because now I'm threatening f5 and
that is something that black has to
prevent he cannot just play this after
f5 this is overwhelming already I think
you know you cannot it's very difficult
to fend off the kingside play but still
I think like is fine and after f4
probably just take and give this Bishop
a little bit of new life okay I went F
form and team went into this yeah maybe
there are some ways to improve here of
course I can just take here that's
stupid
I've done that that's a bit better
because Knight takes Bishop g5 is a
somewhat annoying pinned yeah that's
that's what I should have done but
that's better
this is too that is too simplistic
there's just nothing nothing happening
surprised that the engine gives black an
advantage actually I mean I didn't think
I had anything but I was thinking it's
roughly equal g5 is interesting so play
gaining the space and I think this is
absurd
this is what the engine wants to do
control those squares it's interesting
definitely yeah I mean what he did is of
course fine like this
97 and yeah now just do anything else
but you have 7f that is just giving it
away
Oh 95 I didn't see that one yeah okay
but that's enough
I should age 605 so what is actually the
Bishop g7 is quickest wise it's
convincing at least he takes yeah I was
also thinking to play this that also
looks very strong but if you can keep
the peace why not that's it's easy no
yeah I don't think a3 is a very great
line but maybe it's playable without
being in terrible shape I guess okay
guys thanks for watching